بسبب covet 19 قيود مهمة جدًا أه
قيود وشروط مهمة
جدًا لأداء
طرق مبتكرة للغاية لأداء
الرومرة بأمان ونعلم أننا تجاوزنا
الحمد لله هذه
الأيام القليلة وكل ذلك بنجاح
وأيضًا
خلال موسم الرأس كان
أداء الحج ناجحًا للغاية دون أي  الكشف عن أو
أي سجل أه لأي حالة مؤسسية 19
ما هي القواعد الحالية التي
تضمنها وزارة الصحة
والوكالات الأخرى التي تضمن اختيار
الحجاج أو اختيار
الزوار أو أولئك
الذين سيؤدونهم وفقًا للمعايير
لذلك  أن
الأشخاص المعرضين للخطر في مجموعة
المخاطر لن يكونوا في قائمة الأولويات ،
ثانيًا ، التحكم في عدد
وتدفق الأشخاص الذين يدخلون إلى الحرم
لأداء
الرامرا.المسافات بين الناس
ستكون أيضًا قادة صحيين سيشاركون
في ومرافقة كل مجموعة
ناهيك عن أن
أقنعة الوجه ستكون موجودة
طوال الأداء  هي سعة المستشفى
في مكة المكرمة والمدينة المنورة
لاستيعاب أي هروب في
حال حدوثها أه بشكل عام
حول المملكة سعة العطاءات
سواء كانت مزايدة عادية
أو عزلة أو مرافعات عناية مركزة
زيادة وهذا يشمل المدن المقدسة
أه فقط لإعطاء  على سبيل المثال ، زادت
وحدات العناية المركزة التي تمثل أكثر
النقاط تحديًا
أه تقريبًا إلى
مبلغ 50 أو النسبة المئوية للزيادة بنسبة 50 في
المائة
في توفر وحدات العناية
المركزة ولم نشهد بالفعل
أي لمسة إلى الحد الأقصى أو
مستوى التشبع في
أي من أه لدينا  مدن أو مناطق
في المملكة منذ
بداية هذا
الوباء وحتى الآن ، كانت حالاتك في الوقت الحاضر
أقل بكثير بعد
حدوث واحدة من أعلى الحوادث
في المنطقة ولكن
لديك حوالي 336000
حالة وما يقرب من 5000
حالة وفاة إجمالاً ، فكيف  هل تقيم
طريقة المملكة أه في التعامل مع
هذا وكيف
تمكنت أخيرًا من السيطرة على تفشي المرض
هناك أكثر من  230 مركزًا
يستقبل الأشخاص الذين تظهر عليهم أي
أعراض ويوجد 21 ممرًا للسيارات والعديد
من الأماكن الأخرى التي تستقبل الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
أعراض بدون أعراض بغض النظر عن
وضعهم
بغض النظر عن أي جنسيات أه أو
حالة أه الإقامة أه يمكنهم
القدوم مجانًا للقيام بهذا الشيء
وأيضًا مجانًا
إذا تم تشخيص الحالة على أنها إيجابية ، فسيتم
علاجها ، فهناك
ثلاثة مراكز وطنية تبحث في
كل هذه النتائج وتقوم بالمحاكاة
والقيام بالتنبؤات ، لذلك نحن لا
نتفاعل مع الموقف فحسب ، بل
نتفاعل معه بشكل استباقي أيضًا ، علمنا للأسف
أن  لا ينبغي لأي بلد
أن يشعر بالرضا عن الذات ، فنحن نشهد
موجة ثانية تتفجر في
أوروبا وأماكن أخرى حول العالم ،
ما هي خططك في
حال ضربت الموجة الثانية المملكة العربية السعودية ،
ونقوم بتحليل عميق لجميع البيانات
المتاحة للتأكد من
أننا نعرف ما الذي سيكون أمامنا
نحن مررنا أول 70 إلى 80 يومًا
من أه هذا الوباء مع
قيود التدخلات المبكرة جدًا
تقييد التدخلات للتأكد من
أننا نقوم بقمع المنحنى
ونعود إلى حياتنا ولكن مع الأعراف
الجديدة وهذا الوضع الطبيعي الجديد مهم للغاية لقد فتحنا
أنشطة متعددة ولكن لدينا أكثر
من 100 بروتوكول
لضمان عودة الأشخاص
اجتماعياً أو جنسياً
مع  سلوكيات جديدة ومعايير جديدة مناسبة
السباق على لقاح هو
بالطبع
ما هي خطة
المملكة للحصول على لقاح
وبالفعل
توزيع لقاح داخل المملكة
العربية السعودية نحن جزء
من فعل
الوصول إلى covet 19  مسرع أدوات
حيث
نحن نحن جزء من الدول
المؤسسة لهذا المسرع أه
أه المملكة شاركت بـ 500
مليون أه دولار أمريكي لدعم
الجهود الدولية أه
هناك العديد من
الوكالات المهمة أه غافي
البنك العالمي الصندوق العالمي
مع المشاركين
وبالتأكيد سوف نضمن حصول مجتمعنا
على اللقاح بمجرد الموافقة عليه ليكون
نشطًا
وآمنًا